because it's hard to sell a house
quickly has begun that long Gabrielle
said yeah you're keeping the house
beautifully done by Simmons I mean
talk about eyes to the back their head
bent Simmons and of course the bench
brought the heat back and they're
exposed for a state with that bench JJ
reddick continues his hot shooting
during this homestand Susan the first
footer offensive rebound
just a little stat that would be
noteworthy five of seven Z Miami Heat
are has been knocks down that jumper
come inside the
misson joelle on the defensive end for
his business for him he says well this
guy you mean simmons maybe five giant
steps to cover the court box out the
shooter yeah who's got shooter Belinelli
his first hoop it's a sixer compliments
of Ben Simenson wrote drama roll whose
foreign drug citizens belong for a home
I'm going to finish the job I view this
is a fun angle nice screen holds it
about that pass there Winslow out of the
place six or run here to get it to
single digits would be helpful to the
fact that Sixers have begun a little bit
of a push here a Simmons escape you can
tell it and a foul and Ben will get one
more at the line Brown talked about
getting all the way to the rim able to
extend it absorb the contact labid or
believe those dragons of seven for the
floor off the bench Simmons the set up
of Amir Johnson got it at um - for
Johnson compliments event Simmons
gotta ask yourself what are the legs
like for this heat having played in
Toronto yesterday law what
finished by Simmons take a look at
action just a little while ago Ben with
the rebound the body control Simmons
with a hot potato has to get rid of it
sinning better moments look at this the
ball is clearly out of his hand
and the shot clock is nowhere near going
up we're at point three so with all due
respect to the officials tonight they're
having an awful night Bank Walton's
mountain ash for the crowd Booker Booker
makes it a possession game and plenty of
time eight almost doubled the number of
rebounds
- throws it down
and the Sixers lead for the TEL guards
to do this find a guard and then run to
the rim he gets it to JJ grievance
[Music]
[Applause]
sentence tuck it back and throw it down
there here's the drive again
Winslow just a little short gets the
steal and takes it back tonight they
trail by 24 Redick for three
[Applause]